When I had my first kid,
all of the relationships in my life had to change.
And I think this is a really common struggle for new parents
is that all of a sudden,
they're looking at the relationships with their siblings,
with their family, with their in laws, um,
all completely differently,
because now you're looking through an entirely new lens.
I know for me, as a people pleaser,
my whole life, I accepted the status quo with all of my relationships
and just wanted to keep the peace.
But once it wasn't really about me anymore,
once it was the priority of my children,
everything changed. Because
not only does having a child make you re evaluate how you were raised,
you realize that keeping the peace isn't worth it
if it's gonna be stepping all over all of your, like,
parental instincts.
And I feel like I've also even seen this transition happen
when people get married. People who decide to be child free
or can't have children because of circumstances.
When they're prioritizing their safety and happiness
and well being of their partner versus a family member
or extended family member or parent,
all of the dynamics need to shift or can shift.
Because you're more likely to accept the status quo
that you grew up with if it's just about you,
but once it's about somebody you love,
now you're ready to set some boundaries.